ils datent de 1975 et n'a jamais fait
l'objet de grands travaux
le lycée franco allemand de buc va être
rajeuni les façades seront rénovés pour
un aspect plus moderne et de nouvelles
salles vont être construites une volonté
de l'établissement et du département de
proposer un bâtiment en accord avec son
époque
l'établissement comme il est aujourd'hui
n'étaient plus adaptés aux nouveaux
besoins
aujourd'hui il ya un gros développement
sur les sur le développement numérique
toutes les salles sont câblés demain il
y aura des tablettes quasiment partout
les élèves et aujourd'hui les
infrastructures ne perdais ne permettait
pas ce déploiement de numérique début
des travaux au printemps 2017
le bâtiment actuel sera restructuré une
extension de cinq mille mètres carrés
sera construite
le projet prévoit la création d'une
salle de musique une autre de sciences
et d'un cdi
autre nouveauté une salle polyvalente
d'une capacité de 300 places
la restructuration est importante parce
qu'elle va nous donner des surfaces
supplémentaires de manière à pouvoir
monter en puissance au niveau des
effectifs ce qui nous donnera aussi des
possibilités de rentabiliser nos options
ouvrir peut-être l'une ou l'autre
d'adoption est en tout cas d'étendre
notre offre de compléter notre offre
nous a mis notre deux élèves avec
l'école primaire et le collège
l'établissement accueille en tout plus
de 800 élèves
avec ces travaux il espère porter ses
effectifs à 1200 chiffré à 40 millions
d'euros le chantier devrait être terminé
pour la rentrée 2010 9